this is believed to be the now missing
tourist boat leaving the marina for a
sightseeing trip
but the waters surrounding the
picturesque saratoco peninsula are now a
scene of tragedy
the boat had sent a distress signal to
the coast guard just after one yesterday
afternoon saying they had taken on water
and were beginning to tilt
two hours later they lost contact
26 people including two children were on
board
a mammoth rescue effort with patrol
boats helicopters and divers is ongoing
so far the bodies of ten people
seven men and three women have been
recovered
today a disaster prevention helicopter
in hokkaido will also participate in the
search activity
in cooperation with the japanese coast
guard the self-defense forces and the
police we will do our utmost to rescue
people whose safety is unknown
it's reported everyone on board was
wearing a life jacket sea conditions had
been rough with waves up to two meters
high
prime minister says searches will
continue until everyone is accounted for
relevant organizations will continue to
do their utmost in search and rescue
activities with the highest priority on
saving lives
the government's transport ministry is
looking into the operators safety
standards this is their third incident
in two years
the latest is now under investigation
whilst emergency services continue to
search for any sign of survival
ashton harinag sky news